It is time for Drew's News,
where the soup de jour always good news chowder
and with me at the desk, world's best co-pilot,
Ross Matthew.
Aww, hi, everybody, hi.
(crowd applauding)
All right, well, this story intrigued me to no end.
Iconic bombshell Pamela Anderson is ready to tell
her own story, on her own terms.
Variety reports that a documentary all about her personal
and professional life is coming to none other than Netflix.
Yep, that's the place to do it.
Pamela said on social media that she's not a victim
but a survivor and alive to tell the real story
and both her sons reposted this note,
highlighting the words real story.
So obviously they're behind their mom.
I'm now curious with this real story,
what the, maybe the family feels the film, "Pam and Tommy".
The one on Hulu right now.
Yes.
Yes, I love it
and I do think, and I would have to say I would not love it
if it was taking her down.
I already was a Pam Anderson fan, but my empathic support
for this woman has grown exponentially
while watching Lily James portray her
in such a beautiful way, so I'll be interested
to see what Pam's take is 'cause she's criticized the show.
She wants to set the record straight on her own terms.
I'm just glad to see the show is not doing her a disservice
but actually really opening up my eyes to the sexist,
incredible victim wave that she was set up for.
(crowd applauding)
Well, it's interesting.
You know, I like the "Pam and Tommy" series as well.
I like it a lot, but if they were making a series
about your life, well, for starters, if it was my life,
it'd be way more boring than their life.
But you know, no matter how they tell your story,
you still want to get it out your way, your versions.
I agree, I hear that.
And she's in the zeitgeist
right now, she's been very, very private for years
and years, right?
Yes.
And now she's everywhere
and how smart for her to come out and say
this is what really happened, good for you.
Good for you.
I just love that the "Pam and Tommy Show"
is setting her up to tell her own story and in that way
of just because you are in Playboy, I was in Playboy.
Okay, great, fine.
You do that at a certain point in your life.
You're, you know, an exhibitionist and you're into freedom
and that's what you're doing,
that does not allow anything more to come
into the boundaries and I just, I love the discussion
that this story is posing about what's okay
to do to somebody because of their own actions
and what's not and I'm excited to hear what she has to say.
Me too and most importantly,
you've convinced me to do Playboy, so thank you so much.
I'm in, I'm in.
(crowd applauding)
Ross.
I'll finally call them back.
All right.
I think you would be in Playgirl.
Whatever who cares, either way, you know you're buying it.
You know, you wanna see it.
By the way, you are such a Playgirl.
You think so?
Literally.
I wanna be centerfold.
That's my one demand.
Oh my God.
I wanna fold me out.
(crowd applauding)
Moving on, all right.
All right, hey, next up SNL's Pete Davidson
is always full of surprises and guess what?
He's shocking us again.
People reports he may be headed into space,
who saw that one coming, right?
He's in talks to ride in Jeff Bezos's rocket,
the Blue Origin.
So remember William Shatner went up in space with Bezo
and then Michael Strahan hand went up there.
Yeah, yep
Well, think about this, Pete,
what's been going on in 2022 for him?
He just bought a ferry boat.
He's dating Kim Kardashian.
(crowd applauding)
So like he's done just about everything he can do here
on earth, so maybe he should go up.
So you wouldn't say to him, sky's the limit?
I would not say to him sky's the limit, but you know,
if you have like a bingo card of what Pete Davidson's
gonna do next, going to space wasn't on mine.
But I mean like, what is,
any predictions of what he'll do, grow a mustache,
get a pet unicorn, who knows?
I mean, he could do anything.
Oh, he'd look good in a mustache.
He would.
Yeah, he would actually.
I think he's just so charming, you know?
It's like, he's funny, he's handsome.
I know people who work with him
and they just say what a lovely human being he is,
respectful of his mom.
Oh, I love.
Lover of women, like a romantic.
Yeah, he is a lover of women, right?
There's a reason they're all flocking
and I think he's got, you know, the goods and the real deal.
If you know what I mean?
I think I know what you mean.
(upbeat music)